[Musique]
environ une quarantaine de personnes
étaient présentes c'est donc hier donc
ça fait à peu près 25 % de l'effectif
total de l'établissement est à peu près
50% de l'effectif présent hier pour
l'égalité pour de traitement pour tout
le personnel parce que dans
l'établissement il ya il ya différentes
il ya différents secteurs et donc un
secteur sanitaire et un secteur médico
social et donc le médico-social donc n'a
pas touché les 183 euros prévus en fait
c'est pas une prime en fait c'est un
complément un 17-2 de salaires donc en
fait au final dans l'établissement il y
aura une partie du personnel qui
touchera donc 183 euros en plus voilà et
c'est pas tout le monde n'est pas
concerné
[Musique]
nous on veut même motif même hôpital
même carrière en fait voilà et que le
décret le décret concerne tout le
personnel aussi le personnel
médico-social et que ce soit que qui
soit fait refait dans le dans les plus
brefs délais et que ce soit rétroactif
au ski au final aussi patrons ont fait
le mais exactement le même travail que
quelqu'un dans le sanitaire mais au
final pas on n'est pas payé